[Musique]
l'amour c'est l'infini mise à la portée
des calèches et chris céline dans voyage
au bout de la nuit
cette formule moqueuse signifie que les
hommes survalorise l'amour et quand cela
il se bercent d'illusions ils en sont
même ridicule si un chien de grand-mère
est capable d'aimer c'est bien qu'il n'y
a là nul mystère nul transcendance nul
élévation de l'âme ce jugement
pessimistes nous pousse à réfléchir à la
valeur de l'amour le dictionnaire de
l'académie française donne au verbe
aimer deux sens principaux c'est tout
d'abord éprouvé pour quelqu'un a une
inclination tendant à l'union mais c'est
peut être aussi apprécier une chose le
verbe renvoie bien sûr aux noms comme un
amour qu'on peut définir comme un
intense sentiment d'attachement qui rend
l'être humain capable de faire
abnégation de son intérêt individuel le
verbe aimer frappe l'esprit par son
pouvoir évocateur prononcé seuls il nous
fait prendre la mesure de tout ce qu'il
représente il nous communique le
sentiment de la transcendance propre au
sentiment amoureux
le dire ou l'écrire ainsi c'est donc
conférer à l'acte des mets une valeur
très spécial unique et précieux or cette
valeur sacrée relève pour nous de
l'évidence qui oserait contredire serge
gainsbourg lorsqu'il chante dans la
javanaise que la vie nous vaut d'être
vécue sans amour aimer pensons-nous et
ceux qui donnent tout leur sens à nos
existences
il faut tu aimais des choses et surtout
il faut aimer des êtres cette idée et le
présupposé majeur de toute notre culture
de ce point de vue d'innombrables
chansons films romans pièces de théâtre
poème peintures ne sont que des
variations sur un seul et même thème des
répétitions pour confirmer notre
croyance
pour ancrer notre inébranlable foi en
l'amour
pourquoi donc aimé serait-il si
essentiel il s'agit de trouver les
fondements de notre certitude mais la
valeur sacrée que nous accordons à
l'amour est elle pour autant naturel est
intangible peut-être prenons nous en la
matière comme souvent nos préjugés pour
des vérités universelles
faudra-t-il alors relégué l'amour au
rang des illusions et renoncer à en
tirer un quelconque sens aimé est il
forcément ce qui donne du sens à notre
existence
si l'importance de l'amour paraît de
prime abord consubstantielle à la vie
même sa sacralisation serait en réalité
le propre d'une époque et d'une culture
c'est pourquoi il faudrait apprendre à
aimer afin de réaliser la promesse de
sens de l'amour
l'amour est essentielle dans notre
existence parce qu'il servirait la vie
même
il semble tout d'abord qu'est mais les
choses favorise la survie de l'individu
le sens commun dit que l'être humain
accorde de la valeur à une chose parce
qu'ils en tirent un surcroît de
bien-être mais on peut faire l'hypothèse
que le bien-être accompagne un bénéfice
par exemple nous aimons le soleil parce
que sa lumière a de nombreux bienfaits
pour le corps humain ou encore nous
préférons la nourriture très caloriques
parce que cette préférence a longtemps
favorisé notre survie lorsque les
ressources étaient rares et que les
animaux nous empêcher d'y accéder la
psychologie évolutionniste affirme que
le bien-être associés aux choses que
nous et non à une vertu adaptatif peau
bentham la condition humaine se ramène à
une balance des plaisirs et des pelles
c'est à eux seuls écrit-il qu'il
appartient de nous indiquer ce que nous
devons faire comme de déterminer ce que
nous ferons introduction aux principes
de morale et de législations les
penchants naturels de l'individu
seraient les critères les plus fiables
pour guider son action
nous aurions donc intérêt à aimer les
choses que la vie nous dicte des mais en
prolongeant le raisonnement à l'échelle
collective
on a rivalisé que l'amour sexuel
favorise la survie de l'espèce
l'enjeu de la passion amoureuse
dépasserait donc l'individu cela
expliquerait pourquoi le désir sexuel
apparaître à la fois plus naturel et
plus puissant que toute autre forme
d'aspiration seulement son association à
géométrie variable avec le sentiment
amoureux brouille les pistes et rend
l'idée de la ruse de l'espèce
déplaisante
nous comprenons bien la finalité de la
pulsion sexuelle chez les animaux mais
l'amour humain
croyons-nous ne se réduit pas à cela
schopenhauer infirment cette croyance il
pose que la reproduction est le seul but
véritable de toute passion amoureuse
derrière les apparences derrière tous
les discours sur l'amour c'est la
volonté de l'espèce qui prévaut le
philosophe affirme même que
l'individualisation du sentiment
amoureux
c'est à dire la sélection précise de
l'est mais vise l'amélioration de
l'humanité en découlent l'attirance des
contraires
les hommes de petite taille par exemple
recherche les femmes grandes les blonds
aime les brunes et c'est métaphysique de
l'amour cette hypothèse amusante et
douteuse mais elle ne valide pas l'idée
selon laquelle c'est le destin de
l'espèce qui se joue dans l'amour
passion
le même raisonnement permettent enfin
d'expliquer l'importance de l'amour du
prochain
cette inclination naturelle favorise la
survie du groupe
cette idée c'est clair à la lumière de
l'histoire de l'humanité pendant très
longtemps nous avons vécu en tribu d'une
centaine d'individus maximum tous les
membres se connaissaient personnellement
et les relations intimes suffisaient à
assurer la cohésion de la collectivité
la solitude et l'intimité étaient rares
la promiscuité et l'interdépendance
était la règle
voici donc pourquoi la compagnie et le
souci d'autrui serait des penchants
signer chez l'être humain
richard dawkins dévoile le sens
biologique de ses penchants notre
altruisme n'est pas désintéressée car à
l'origine il protège notre patrimoine
génétique dans cette théorie
l'amour du prochain dérives de la
tendance d'un gène a aidé les répliques
de lui-même se trouvant dans d'autres
corps pourquoi les parents aiment-ils
leurs enfants parce que leurs gènes ont
intérêt à investir dans des individus
plus faibles qui pourront préserver et
transmettre leurs répliques l'amour
universel et le bien-être des espèces en
général sont des concepts qui n'ont
absolument aucun sens quand on parle
d'évolution estime l'éthologue dans le
gène égoïste
aimer son prochain serait donc aussi un
avantage évolutif
si l'importance de l'amour nous semble
relever de l'évidence c'est parce
qu'elle serait inscrite dans la vie même
mais à y regarder de plus près la valeur
exceptionnelle que nous voyons dans
l'acte dé mais n'est peut-être pas aussi
naturel qu'il n'y paraît
en consultant l'histoire nous nous
rendons compte que l'amour n'a pas
toujours eu la place qu'il a aujourd'hui
dans nos vies
la valorisation de l'amour des choses
peut apparaître comme une conséquence du
progrès de liberté individuelle en effet
l'injonction moderne à faire ce que l'on
aime n'a de sens que parce qu'un grand
nombre d'options s'offrent à l'individu
il est libre de choisir ce qu'ils aiment
et d'en jouir ses affinités sa sexualité
ses convictions sa religion son métier
son lieu de vie et bien sûr en tant que
consommateur client roi
les produits et les services qui lui
plaisent puis il est libre de changer
d'avis en tant que citoyen d'une
démocratie il exerce sa liberté
d'appréciation lorsqu'il les lycées
dirigeants dans l'existentialisme est un
humanisme sartre met en lumière la
radicalité de cette liberté de
l'individu qui doit s'inventer lui même
plutôt que de recevoir son identité des
traditions en particulier puisque dieu
n'existe pas l'homme ne peut se
raccrocher à rien mais il est libre
condamné à être libres écrit le
philosophe l'homme n'est rien d'autre
que son projet il n'est donc rien
d'autre que l'ensemble de ses actes
rien d'autre que sa vie ainsi c'est
parce que nous sommes à radicalement
libre que choisir préféré c'est à dire
aimer les choses devient un acte d'une
valeur fondamentale la valorisation de
l'amour passion serait elle une
construction culturelle l'amour avec un
grand a devient un mythe occidental
entre les 11e et 15e siècle avec la fin
des invasions barbares la vie sociale se
stabilise et se développe donc les
interactions entre les deux sexes sont
plus fréquentes mais surtout les
croisades donne l'occasion à de nombreux
chevaliers célibataire de convoiter les
femmes riches et et seul voire veuves
des seigneurs partie de combat c'est
l'amour courtois comme la dame et de par
son statut social inatteignable pour le
chevalier célibataire celui-ci fantasme
survalorise l'objet de sondés
dire effets de sa conquête la grande
affaire de son existence
denis de rougemont estime que cette
nouvelle conception de l'amour et
d'inspiration religieuse elle plongerait
ses sources dans le catharisme une secte
chrétienne contemporaine du roman
courtois pour laquelle la souffrance et
la condition de l'élévation spirituelle
alors apparaît dans la culture
occidentale du 12e siècle et en
particulier dans les poèmes des
troubadours l'amour passion le fai
d'adorer en souffrent un être
inaccessible ce qui exalte le lyrisme
occidentale écrit rougemont c'est moins
l'amour comble est que la passion
d'amour et passion signifie souffrance
l'amour et l'occident la sacralisation
de l'amour passion serait donc un
phénomène culturel occidental
on peut arriver à la même conclusion en
étudiant la forme d'amour aujourd'hui
supérieure à toutes les autres
l'amour parental la théorie de
l'évolution explique certes pourquoi il
s'agit d'un attachement crucial il en va
de la perpétuation de l'espèce et plus
précisément des gènes mais est ce bien
la nature qui nous dicte de voir ans
l'enfant un être sacré au sens
étymologique c'est-à-dire digne de
sacrifice à la vérité cette attitude est
historiquement récente elle commence à
la fin du xviie siècle en europe alors
que les parents donnaient à l'enfant une
valeur inférieure à celle d'un adulte
ils se mettent à l'est mais de manière
inconditionnelle philippe ariès lit ce
nouveau sentiment au mariage d'amour en
effet le consentement des époux
introduit l'affection dans le mariage et
par là dans la famille
la famille commence alors à s'organiser
autour de l'enfant écrit l'historien à
lui donner une importance telle qu'il
sort de son ancien d'anonymat on ne peut
pas sans grande peine le perdre et le
remplacer l'enfant et la vie familiale
sous l'ancien régime
ainsi même la valorisation de l'amour
qui nous semble le plus important serait
en réalité le propre d'une époque et
d'une culture et mais paraît certes
d'une importance cruciale pour la vie
même mais le sentiment d'un fini que
nous inspire le verbe à lui seul ce
sentiment puissant peut être religieux
n'exprimerais pas une réalité éternelle
les hommes changent et l'amour change
avec eux faut-il pour autant renoncé à
chercher du sens dans l'acte d'aimer
[Musique]
puisque la plénitude que le mort d'inr
s'attend à recevoir de l'amour est une
croyance qui a germé dans l'évolution de
la vie sociale c'est à l'homme en quête
de sens d'apprendre à aimer afin de
réaliser la promesse de l'amour il doit
tout d'abord apprendre à aimer les
choses
qu'est ce à dire à l'évidence il ne
s'agit pas d' aimer les choses comme on
les aime communément il ne s'agit pas de
préféré comme nous l'a inculquer
l'évolution ce qui favorise notre survie
ni de choisir comme nous le permettre
nous libertés individuelles les éléments
de notre identité
la morale stoïcienne offre une solution
pour aimer avec plus de profondeur
l'homme peut retrouver du sens dans son
rapport aux choses en cultivant l'amour
du destin et beckett conseil dans son
manuel de vouloir que les choses
arrivent comme elle arrive
par conséquent le stoïcien accompli
n'apprécie pas certaines choses plus que
d'autres ils les estiment toutes aussi
bonnes les unes que les autres
en s'accordant ainsi avec l'ordre de la
nature
ils s'accordent avec lui même et
retrouve l'unité de sa vie spirituelle
nietzsche reprendra à son compte cet
idéal en définissant la sagesse la plus
haute parce qu'il nommait la mort faty
l'amour du destin de ce qui est là
devant nous ici et maintenant ce serait
donc en habitant chaque instant de la
vie qu'on pourrait s'épanouir en aimant
en second lieu l'homme en quête de sens
doit apprendre à dépasser l'amour
passion cette forme d'amour ne peut que
le décevoir car elle est par nature
instable
lamoureux ne sait pas quand est né son
sentiment ni quand il finira mais le
fond du problème c'est la logique
perverse du désir eros et l'amour qui se
nourrit de l'absence la flamme de la
passion brûle tant que le manque et les
obstacles entretiennent le fantasme
puis elle s'éteint paradoxalement en
présence de l'aimer plate on en déduit
que la forme d'amour la plus haute la
seule porteuse de sens ne procède plus
du désir
c'est pourquoi la beauté du corps ne
peut pas inspiré la transcendance de
l'amour le philosophe refuse donc l'idée
moderne selon laquelle le rapprochement
des corps peut servir le rapprochement
des coeurs de son point de vue il est
impossible de spiritualiser l'acte
sexuel
celui qui thème est celui qui aime ton
âme fait-il dire à socrate dans la halle
6 biad majeur
l'amour et créateur de sens si et
seulement si il est une passion absolue
à la fois intellectuelle et religieuse
apprendre à aimer ce serait donc
apprendre à aimer l'essence de l'être
aimé
mais il faut encore trouver du sens dans
l'amour du prochain la psychologie
évolutionniste nous dit que cette forme
d'attachement n'est que l'atavisme de
notre longue interdépendance dans la vie
tribale et la biologie de l'evolution
part du principe que notre altruisme et
forcément borné par l'égoïsme de nos
gènes
cela nous condamne-t-il pour autant à
aimer comme le veut la nature ne pouvons
nous pas là aussi comme pour l'amour
passion imaginez dépasser nos penchants
ordinaire le christianisme promeut un
tel idéal celui d'un amour à radical car
universel et inconditionnel dans cet
idéal les actions humaines sont
entièrement tournés vers l'amour
prochain tu aimeras ton prochain comme
toi-même comme en jésus-christ dans
l'évangile selon matthieu il faut aimer
son semblable quels qu'ils soient et lui
faire du bien sans rien attendre en
retour
cet effort sera encore plus porteur de
sens s'il vise ceux qui ne le méritent
pas aimez vos ennemis et fait du bien à
ceux qui vous haïssent bénissez ceux qui
vous maudissent priez pour ceux qui vous
dit femme précise le christ dans
l'évangile selon saint luc
le verbe aimer évoque pour nous à lui
seul toute la profondeur de l'amour nous
ressentons en le lisant ou en
l'entendant qu'il exprime ce qu'il y a
d'essentiel dans nos existences
de fait l'importance de l'amour serait
consubstantielle à la vie même et mais
c'est tout d'abord survivre
l'individu aime les choses que lui a
dicté le long de l'évolution la pression
de l'environnement
la femme aime l'homme et réciproquement
parce qu'il en va de la perpétuation de
l'espèce
les membres d'un groupe cm parce qu'ils
sont interdépendants cette analyse
n'explique cependant pas pourquoi nous
pensons aujourd'hui qu'aimer et
pourvoyeur de sens et en effet cette
idée est récente
à l'échelle de l'histoire de l'humanité
en occident aimé et sacré depuis que
nous sommes plus libres de vivre comme
nous l'entendons depuis que l'idéal de
l'amour courtois s'est diffusé dans
toute la société
et depuis que la famille est devenue un
lieu d'affection la promesse de sens du
verbe aimer nettel donc qu'une illusion
propre à notre culture moderne
peut-être faut-il en réalité pour
réaliser cette promesse
apprendre à aimer
apprendre à aimer le destin apprendre à
aimer l'âme plutôt que le corps et
apprendre à aimer radicalement tous les
hommes
certes ce n'est pas facile surtout pour
les caniches
[Musique]
avant de vous laisser j'ai une question
pour vous et si vous pouviez jeter votre
cours sur le thème à la poubelle et si
vous pouviez réussir les dissertations
culture générale des concours mais aussi
les déesses de votre prêt pas avec
seulement dix pages
depuis que j'ai popularisé ma méthode
des paragraphes en 2016
les élèves qui l'adoptent gagnaire
rapidement des points tout en gagnant
beaucoup de temps ça vous intéresse je
vous révèle les cinq étapes de ma
méthode
dans la vidéo qui apparaît maintenant à
l'écran vous pouvez également la trouver
en écrivant prépa hec méthode des
paragraphes dans la barre de recherche
de youtube
regardez-la attentivement jusqu'au bout
et vous saurez exactement comment gagner
facilement des points en dissertation de
culture générale cette année tout en
gagnant beaucoup de temps